that's where we begin Anthony with a
very blunt warning on the coronavirus
from the nation's top doctor Yale
Surgeon General Jerome Adams says this
week most Americans will face the
hardest and saddest time of their lives
across the nation more than three
hundred thirty-seven thousand cases of
corona virus are reported but the real
toll is likely much higher more than
9,600 Americans have died the outbreak
is slamming hospitals across the country
including in New York where cases surged
over the weekend here in New York our
lead national correspondent David beg no
spent time inside a hospital in a
desperate situation this morning he's
outside the Navy hospital ship comfort
docked in Manhattan David what's
happening there Anthony the president
yesterday assured New York that the
hospital ship comfort is ready but only
30 of the 1000 available beds actually
have patients in them the ship was not
supposed to treat Kovac patients but
we're being told that if there's a need
they will do it here on the ship and
there's a real need around New York City
in fact the federal government sent a
thousand workers into hospitals to help
out and we did ask to go inside that
Brooklyn Hospital and we're allowed
inside and they are doing everything
they can right now
[Music]
some of them required intubation the
second they hit the door here at
Brooklyn Hospital Center nearly 80% of
the patients are being treated for the
corona virus
dr. Joshua Rosenberg is on the front
line and has been for weeks based on
what he's seen he has a stark warning
for the nation's hospitals to the rest
of the country who are lagging behind
New York and I pray that it doesn't get
that level on any way shape or form god
forbid it does I hope that they're
taking this lead time to get organized
public health officials say the u.s. is
now entering one of the most critical
weeks of this crisis another Park in New
York City is designated to be converted
into a field hospital within days the
death toll could peak in places like New
York Michigan and Louisiana but next
week is going to be our Pearl Harbor
moment it's going to be our 9/11 moment
it's going to be the hardest moment for
many Americans in their entire life I
think we all know that we have to reach
a certain point and that point is going
to be a horrific point in terms of death
but it's also a point at which things
are going to start changing today
Louisiana is expected to open a
makeshift 1,000 bed hospital inside the
Convention Center in New Orleans the
state has more than 13,000 cases today
Texas State Troopers will stop drivers
at the Louisiana border asking them for
documentation on where they're going and
if they're staying in the state they'll
need to self quarantine for two weeks
Cheryl PABA tells mother Susana and her
father Alberto both died in the same New
Jersey hospital a week apart due to
complications from coronavirus they both
died alone Cheryl said goodbye to her
father on FaceTime she and her siblings
weren't even allowed to have a funeral
when the guy cremated we couldn't even
hug each other because we just FaceTime
and then we prayed through FaceTime
that's how he had his there service
Cheryl's parents were married for 44
years this morning her uncle who also
has coronavirus is in the ICU fighting
for his life
there may be some good news that we got
from New York's governor yesterday the
number of deaths has been far fewer the
number of hospitalizations actually
recently was under 600 and the number of
people being discharged from the
hospital has risen considerably
it sounds like good news but the
governor says it's too early to tell if
that's just a blip on the radar or if
it's a trip we will be back at 7:30 to
bring you more of our report from inside
that ICU
possibly some glimmers of hope there
David thank you very much